(audience applauding)
By the way, have you looked up your Uber rating?
I just did, and I'm a little upset.
Because I think I'm very nice
to my Uber drivers, beyond nice.
At one point, I even offered to drive.
(everyone laughing)
I'm like the best.
I'm the best person you want.
I don't want music, I don't want anything,
I don't complain, I don't do anything.
I got a 4.88.
I rate them five stars, no matter what.
Every time?
What am I gonna do?
What am I gonna ruin somebody's life?
They drive me in a car, I go five, I don't care.
Five?
I dunno if I'll ever see you again.
Five, five, five, I dunno.
What am I gonna give rate people?
Once we start rating people, this is gonna be the disaster
of a society where it's like, "Hi, I'm a 3.5."
"Yeah, I figured."
Well, it turns out
you have a higher rating than I do.
Oh, this is unbelievable,
but we've been in Ubers together.
Many times and we will be in many more.
You know, I did some interview about you recently.
Really?
Yeah and they asked me.
They said, "What's it like meeting Drew Barrymore"
"for the first time?"
"You remember the first time, is she iconic?"
You know, and I said, "Yeah, she is."
I go, "It's like meeting the Statue of Liberty."
(audience laughing)
"And then after a hundred dance parties later,"
"she's still the Statue of Liberty"
"but you just kind of hung out with her,"
"and you got to know who the Statue of Liberty is."
You're the one and only, you're Drew Barrymore.
You're iconic.
(audience applauding)
You're quite the Statue of Liberty.
Yeah, it's something like that.
When people meet you...
People freak out when they meet you.
I've been with you when people meet you.
So, the Uber drivers might freak out and be like...
"How could I give more than five stars, one star."
I don't know what they do.
Look at this.
Yes!
(audience applauding)
This is this how everyone sees you.
(upbeat music)